the future of the loup-garou of this
country is precisely as bright or as
dark so huge babka
that's influential American author James
Baldwin in the documentary I am Not sure
Negro Baldwin's iconic essays and novels
explore race justice and power in
America most notably during the civil
rights era
we asked 18-year old poet play on
Patrick to narrate some of Baldwin's
work it comes as a great shock to
discover at the country which is your
birthplace and to which you owe your
life and your identity as not in its
whole system of reality evolved any
place for you the brutality with which
Negroes are treated in this country
simply cannot be overstated however
unwilling white men may be to hear it in
the beginning and neither can this be
overstated an ego just cannot believe
that white people are treating him as
they do he does not know what he has
done Samaritan
[Applause]
[Music]
and in fact the truth about the black
man as a historical entity and as a
human being has been hidden from him
deliberately and cruelly the power of
the white world is threatened whenever a
black man refuses to accept the white
rose definition so every attempt is made
to cut that black man down
not only was made yesterday but is made
today all the Western nations has been
best placed to prove the uselessness and
obsolescence of the concept of color but
it is not dare to accept this
opportunity or even to conceive of it as
an opportunity color is not a human or
personal reality it is a political
reality but this is a distinction so
extremely hard to make that the West has
not been able to make it yet and at the
center of this dreadful storm this vast
confusion stand the black people of this
nation who must now share the fate of a
nation that has never accepted them to
which they were brought in Chains for a
very long time for example America
prospered or seemed to prosper this
prosperity cost millions of people with
their lives now not even the people who
are the most spectacular recipients of
the benefits of this prosperity are able
to endure these benefits they can either
understand them nor do without them nor
can they go beyond them above all they
cannot or dare not assess or imagine the
price paid by their victims or subjects
for this way of life and so they cannot
afford to know why the victims are
revolting
this is a formula for our nations or
kingdoms decline for no Kingdom can
maintain itself by force alone the best
nation on earth no other country can
afford to dream of a Plymouth and a wife
and a house with a fence and the
children growing up safely to go to
college and to become executives and
then to marry and have the Plymouth's
and a house and so forth a great many
people who do not live this way and
cannot imagine it and do not know that
when we talk about democracy that this
is what we mean
[Music]
what is it you wanted me to reconcile
myself to I was born here almost 60
years ago I'm not gonna live another 60
years you always told me it takes time
it was taking my father's time my
mother's time Uncle Sam my brothers and
my sisters huh my niece's are my
nephew's death how much time do you want
Paul your progress not everything that
is faced can be changed but nothing can
be changed until it is faced
[Music]
you
Patrick is also a youth ambassador for
the Obama Foundation's my brother's
keeper I cannot recommend highly enough
that James Baldwin documentary I am NOT
your negro I haven't seen what stood out
to you is there something one line in
particular there are in the documentary
the whole thing he so much of what this
conversation about today he was saying
in the early 1960s so eloquently it's
it's very moving no I'm embarrassed to
say I haven't seen it but now I will
watch it Anthony
special shout-out special mommy hug to
you my time or of eh-eh for editing that
piece those things are very difficult to
do I say this all the time you see a
piece with no track that takes a lot of
work so you go Tony takes a lot of work
yeah well done yeah well done and well
done play on bring those words to life
again a new generation you're watching
CBS this morning
we'll be right back